l'ho fatta no non ci credo l'ho mai
bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti avessimo
video sono fa dj ci siamo tolti su è più
ogni volta che faccio ai primi spassano
anni quindi non mi stupiscono anche più
usiamo cronometro level da un attimo
sono stat
devo restare per partire trolley anche
simpatico proprio un cazzo mandarà botto
run fantastico però non cade bello fanta
questo livello già mi piace ragazzi una
presa per il culo e devo capire sordo mi
piace come idea to peer
londra qua non mi cade un pianoforte in
testa ormai ma avrei scommesso la
ragazza avrei scommesso davvero nostro
cattivo che ha puntato quasi sta
controllando i livelli in un momento
veramente cosa ho fatto ce l'ha fatta ad
arrivare al traguardo per ok niente i
muri ragazzi sto livello non sto capendo
un cazzo abbiate parlate stata ordinata
davvero che lascia molti livelli che
prendono l'iniziativa machete trova ning
da una scena in machete perché sono di
ostico si sconta sia fammi un favore
affetto ham il pane grazie lo mancata di
brutto però va beh no no mi mi fai un
panino no grazie anche tu un anno ma lo
beccare lui sinceramente 1 peccare
no sono fuori allenamento regalo no ci
sono 700 persona non l'ha beccato un
cazzo come faccia beccarne 2 con una
sbarra ho capito perché non giocavo più
ad air avevo paura di fare figure di
merda e di preciso ci sono anche
riuscito non ho fatto canestro ma gli ho
tirato una testata da madonna
va bene ha voglia di spiegarmi il suo
canestro fatto che il basket è uno sport
violento sicuro socio il gol è la madre
che sognavo fatto una capriola che non
si è mai vista né questo è il
famosissimo ragazzi colpo di culo sto
tizio si è messo in banca un progetto è
il calcio è uno sport violento credo
molto violento organi e non ce la faccio
le case in studio è la madonna
[Applauso]
si appresta al tiro incredibile ancora
col futuro gol fatti vedere replay
perché questo se questo è un colpo di
classe
messi non sei un cazzo in confronto con
le prime skype cos'è questa cosa
facciamo
cosa dovrebbe devo lanciare una spada è
beccato in testa no no no eh ma se si no
per mick e dove sia beccarlo non ce la
faccio
guarda che merda cioè quasi mani e non
ce la farò mai la posso fare
ok
hai presente quando vecchi
avete presente dando mercato qualcuno
con una pallonata in testa ecco più o
meno è andata così
l'urto website cos'è sta cosa sarebbe
bello se serve per tagliare la pizza
quella roba
no è perfetto di qualcosa mi dice di no
qualcosa ecco perche sta tornando
ragazzi sentite io non posso sbagliarmi
di cosa cazzo è successo mi apocalypse
10 e la madonna hanno fatti 10 visti
cosi massimo ricordo non farei bello è
partito benissimo
sono stati in fila per un concerto la
leggenda il cartello non calpestare gli
umani sdraiati niente rega non
rispettano il codice della strada per
titolo prima all'inizio ci ho messo
mezz'ora ci ho messo mezz'ora solo a
capire sta cosa
salve buongiorno posso passare veloce
belli siamo venuti alcuni san fermin e
che cazzo sei tu prendi sto fucilato
grazie babbo molto gentile
l'ho preso numero
e finito così michael j mi sento preso
in causa con quella j quindi lo faceva
il conto le long e spies ok ma io
vincerò subito forse non subito
sì sì no no no no no no no va bene
questo non l'ho capito cosa stai facendo
è di merda non si può fare st pastore
si no non ti chiedo più una sega ma fa
misto a livello per cortesia non ci
muoviamo più sennò si bravo bravissimo
surfing che il cazzo non sa che è un
surfista modello credo buongiorno uomo
in sedia a rotelle senza testa che fa
surf fantastico lob swing hardcore in
orchestrale ultimato ha fatto così con
la sedia con l'assenza intera fantastico
spettante ragazzo e robin li facciamo
dominio sì posso volare a caso veloce
mio dio non ci posso credere cioè se
riesco a sé così questo è stato rop
singh più figo che abbia mai fatto di
provare questo che ancora non valve your
ninja io non ho facciamo difficile che
quella vedo la vedo che sei stronzo mi
sono salvato per come faccio a batterlo
può prenderlo a calci nel culo non è
possibile riuscire a corredo d'altra
parte dell'ocse bevan è neanche partito
negatogli a kg il cozzo si è già fatta
[Musica]
cosa sto facendo vermi che sto provando
mosse da ninja peggiori delle sue
strangolo vivo stronchi strano molla
misura quella era mio braccio comunque
abbiate pazienza mentre ci sto pronto la
mezz'ora
sì sì sì ci togli bravo ma gunnes senti
la tua gamba non mi interessa che quindi
tutti togli bravo grazie a me facciano
andare ad altra fatto impossibile basta
mi sono rotto il cazzo sua yourself
lanciati mi lancio fronte mica ho capito
cos'è sta roba ragazzo ha finito bello e
inter di borse questo no termine questo
devo fare indiano in via mediana
cos'era quella la musa di danza zio la
puoi fare
bravo bravo diana ti manca una scarpa
c'è una calza lancia faccio tanto lo so
lo sapevo ci avrei scommesso niente che
non è possibile fare no ma neanche
aggrapparsi si si no seduta falsi fasi
bravo bravo avuto paura però
sinceramente secret agent you have to
eliminating gang leader entrato in casa
in modo molto step link erano veramente
uno si chiama etti per mandare sono
spente le luci
ok ho ucciso in modo furtivo nello
sistemi di sicurezza all'avanguardia
editi stavo aspettando no edito nomi
stato aiutato gli uomini ninja bella
mostriamo non ha funzionato è stato
bello bravo che sia adesso baciami
promuovi atrocemente fantastico per fan
cos'è sta roba shopper fan bello ma chi
me la sto cavando troppo bene anni ecco
i senza gambe e chissene forte leano
lega è la cosa più difficile che abbia
mai fatto sulla pista
bene così mio dio mio dio che cosa
madonna radio lo slalom perfetto bravo
ragazzo non troppo bravo basta piano
piano no c'è culo è che sto schifo
no è abbastanza bravo a vincere e
pichler fa vj alla birra no fermi un
attimo questo dove dove ho messo la
birra ma perché le dico questo livello a
fa vj da ggg 64 gigi con quella non
possono anche cambiare personaggio come
faccia andare avanti come non detto rega
mi sembra una presa pericolo attenti
alle trappole che cazzo faceva evitarla
si ok ok va bene così che ho fatta no ma
non ci crederò mai
voi non avete visto niente mi ispirano i
vostri livelli solamente belli a volte
comunque ragazzi spero capitoli sia
piaciuta mi mancava e primi saranno un
secolo che non lo facevo tutto il mio
episodio i ragazzi salvi dove è piaciuto
lasciate come al solito un commento mi
piace anche peggiori facebook come nel
video trattando iscrizione senza ore si
iscrive 13 diventiamo nel prossimo video
belle ragazze